Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David Flanagan, although you may
know me from across the Internet and this
channel as Rawkode.
And I often say clustered is the worst
idea I've ever had. I've now taken that
back. This episode is the worst idea I've
ever had.
Echo.
Can I ask if I have an echo?
I'll work on that if I need to.
There is an echo. Two people have said
it now.
If you have an echo, make sure you
don't have two tabs open.
Yes.
There we go.
Yeah. Don't have it open on Twitter at
the same time and cause me get the
fear. Alright.
We're on low latency mode. So we have
around a one second delay from whatever you
type and whatever I see. So we can
have a good conversation today.
And we're gonna have fun. So like I
said, this is the worst episode.
Worst idea I've ever had because I have
broken two clusters.
My goal is to have random members of
the audience come on and join me
and see if they can fix them.
I was really confident when I broke these
clusters that I I was like, yeah. Nobody
will fix this. And now I'm worried that
they're too easy.
So whether this episode is thirty minutes long
or ninety minutes long, I have no idea.
That is down to you, the audience. So
if you haven't seen cluster before, I would
encourage you to check it out.
We pop over to my screen share for
a second. You will see
that there is a cluster
oh, don't do that. There is a cluster
playlist with over 42 of these episodes. So
if you wanna see how people
come on computer. There we go.
Clustered, filled playlist. There's loads of these. Right?
We've had teams from Adobe,
Zapier. We've had members of the community, IBM.
We've had Pixielabs,
Aerospike,
ChainGuard versus ChainGuard. That was a fun one.
Like, there are lots of companies. So go
please check out the other episodes of Clustered
if you wanna do more or see more
people sweat on the stream. Alright.
We're gonna get this thing kicked off in
just a minute. What I need you to
do
is I have created a buzzer for today's
session. If you go to this URL, this
will allow you to register your name,
and we're gonna allow you to buzz in
and join me for ten minutes to see
if you can fix a cluster.
If you don't want to, that's fine. You
can just watch and laugh. There are rules,
Andrew. Yes. No. URI
code has not been used to break any
of these clusters.
So
join the buzzer. And while I do that,
I'm gonna thank our sponsors as well.
So get that at the sponsor's way. Alright.
So from the very start of clustered, we
have been using Teleport. Right? Teleport is what
we use every single week to debug these
clusters and pay it on them. I can,
like I'm gonna do today, add GitHub users
to a GitHub team, and they are magically
gonna have access to these clusters. They can
SSH and and try and fix stuff. So
if you're not familiar with Teleport, please go
to Rawkode.live/Teleport.
It'll make our sponsors happy. It keeps clusters
happening,
and I would be well, yeah, just check
it out. You're gonna love it. I'm gonna
use it all through this episode as well,
so you'll see how amazing it is.
Oh, we've got people on the the buzzer.
Sweet. I was wondering what that noise was.
Also, Equinix metal provide all of the hardware
for clustered, and they have done since the
very beginning. If you wanna check out Equinix
metal, go to Rawkode.live/metal.
Use the code raw code, and that'll get
you $200 in credit to start playing around
with it. These machines are chunky. Right? I
could run clusters on a small DM with
one core and one gig of RAM, but
I don't. I run it on large bare
metals machines with 48 cores and 60 or
90 gig of RAM depending on which instance
I use. Why?
It just makes it a bit more fun.
If you've not tried that, go check it
out.
Alright. Let's put this back down here.
So I can see yeah. We've got people
in there, we can start testing and get
our first person on. I'm gonna reset the
buzzers and lock them.
No cheating.
And we're gonna get our first contestant on.
So I do have space for somebody
here.
So
I'm gonna unlock the buzzers. First one to
buzz in, I will paste the link into
the chat, and you can come and join
me.
Ready, set,
go.
Benjamin
Ritter,
You can come on in.
On our system here, I'm pasting this link
to everybody, but I only want Benjamin to
join.
So click the link, turn on your camera.
We'll get you access to this cluster.
If you're not here in a minute, we'll
pass it over to someone else.
I hope you can hear me, Benjamin.
We have Benjamin.
Hi.
Alright. Let's get you access to this cluster.
I'm assuming you have a GitHub account. Right?
Yeah. I do. Awesome. Okay. So
I'm gonna add you to either cluster one
or cluster cluster two. Do you have a
preference?
I have literally no idea what's going on
the first time here.
So I hope you've read it.
Alright. Let's just give you access to cluster
one.
So if you could tell me what your
username
is, please.
I didn't type it in because that's not
an that's gonna employ if I try to
can
I do
Yep? There's a there's a private chat. Feel
free to use that.
There you go. Thank you very much.
Alright. So this is gonna get you access
to this cluster. You can accept that invite
just now.
Will unlock my
password.
Alright. You have an invite.
Once you've accepted that, you will be able
to log in at join.clusters.live.
This will give you access to the cluster,
and I will show you how to start
fixing it.
Alright.
I'll just hide this over here.
Where where would I find the the invite?
I think it's in GitHub. If you go
to GitHub.com, it should be a notification. You'll
also get an email address at an email
to your to your email.
Oh, yeah. I'll
just do that way.
Sorry about my wife. I'm a little bit
sick right now.
No worries at all.
So how's your Kubernetes experience?
I am a systems engineer and IT consultant
by day. And my main thing is Kubernetes
clusters and operating them for
customers, but mostly managed ones. I'm do I
have one for one customer that's on prem
and that's fully fully managed by by our
team,
including
control plan and everything. It's on headset cloud,
so that should tell you how much manual
work is. Yeah.
And then I'm I'm doing this, like, for
two year two years now. Nice.
Okay.
So I just opened an SSH session onto
one control player.
What that means is if if you go
to join Clustered
Live, you'll be able to log in with
your GitHub authentication.
And then if you click once you're logged
in, click on activity and active sessions, and
you will see my session, and you can
use options and join.
Alright.
So go to act yep. Sweet.
Alright. You now have access to a cube
admin cluster.
I'll give you one bit of advice because
everybody gets this unclustered. You will have to
export your cube config, which I'm happy to
do for you.
Okay.
Then the cube admin location,
Everything should be as unique. Your mission is
to upgrade the clustered application and a default
namespace from version one to version two.
Good luck.
Okay.
And I'll give you ten minutes, and then
we'll we'll give someone else a shot.
You
already exported the cube config, but
is this is this part of the challenge,
or is this a problem?
This is part of the challenge. So it
would appear that you do not have a
working control plan.
Oh, no.
How is this cluster provision?
With Kube admin, Kube ADM. Are you familiar
with Kube ADM?
Vaguely.
Okay. Just true wrappers.
So if we run p s a u
x and grab the cube,
we'll see all of our control plan components.
There's one missing at the moment, which is
the API server.
Okay.
So by joining me, you already get a
$20 Amazon voucher. If at any point you
wanna hand it over to someone else, just
feel free to to say thanks and off
you go. But if you need any advice,
I'm happy to give little hints as we
go. So, you know, don't feel uncomfortable. Don't
feel under pressure.
Like, just do what you're happy with. Of
course.
Okay. Just
just to be real with you for a
moment here, I'm just googling what to do
to restart the API server for now. I
I Google every day. Don't you worry, man.
Yeah. Just just to to keep the viewers
involved and and not staring at a blank
screen. And I found, like, I'm I think
from 02/2017,
which says, oh, just restart the container. I
I guess that won't work since modern Kubernetes
doesn't use Docker anymore. But
There's no Docker on these machines, I'm afraid.
There's container d.
And the way that Kube admin works is
that all of our control plane components are
configured via static manifests.
Okay.
Do we have the the manifests on the
on the control plan notes themselves? They are
indeed. They're in slash e t c slash
Kubernetes slash manifests.
And thank you for using a pager.
That means the audience sees exactly what you
see, which is always great.
Yeah.
Okay.
We got six minutes left to make some
progress.
Alright.
Wanna chat? Help out. You guys are always
really good at this.
Oh, okay. I didn't even think about that.
But it's No. They haven't ticked a lot
too far, but the chat are usually pretty
good at helping. So Alright.
But right now, you you have no API
server.
There are logs for the API server.
I can tell you where those are if
you want to go take a look.
They're in VarLog containers,
which may be a good place to start.
We have a symptom.
Okay. Just
uh-huh.
So this is telling us that our API
server
actually cannot start,
and we're seeing a connection refused on local
host port two three seven nine.
Do we know what port number or application
that may be?
I don't, but we'll find out soon.
Joss, our objective is to upgrade the application
from v one to v two, and the
chat is in there pretty quick. Is down.
It's what you see.
Alright.
Okay. So
It's kinda sad.
Let me look at the manifest here because
it's like mean
okay. That's a good idea.
Oh, don't run cube in cube admin in
it, please.
That will get us in a much worse
position.
But yeah.
Oh, yeah. There's some HCD thing, and there's
no HCD in
in the the locks. Is etcd in this
case part of the
not
like I'm not actually sure.
It's part of the control plane,
most definitely, but
should should it generate a lock? Has is
it has it has it been running at
all?
So I mean This cluster was healthy at
one point today.
SSD was alive. It would appear that it's
currently broken.
You certainly can take a look at the
static manifest
or try to find the logs, I think,
would be a good show.
Okay. That's
no. That's not is is not running. Seems
it is not a problem. Okay.
You've got a couple of minutes left. What
are you thinking? What are you thinking?
I'm thinking I have no fucking clue how
do Can can I can I swear on
this show? You can't swear. Yes. We we
swear all the time on cluster. Don't you,
Lenny? Oh, alright. I have no fucking clue
how to use KubeAdam and how to to
deal with the manifest and how to to
deploy them if they are not deployed and
or check if they're deployed.
Alright. Would you like to swap out, or
do you wanna
I'm a be real with you.
Some somebody else can take it at this
point. I can can Google it. No worries.
Well, thank you for coming on.
Email me. I'll put my email address is
david@rawkode.com.
I'll put that on the stream somewhere. I'll
add it to the the description on YouTube,
and we'll get you that voucher over today.
But thank you for coming on, and we'll
speak to soon. Thanks, man. Bye. Thank you.
It was a it was a pleasure. Alright.
So what we're gonna do is get the
buzzer back on the go.
Now I'm not gonna touch that session or
that cluster. Whoever comes on has the choice
to continue with cluster one or maybe try
their luck with cluster two. That is up
to you.
So the link for our cosmobuzz.net
is on the screen.
I'm going to unlock the buzzers in about
ten seconds time. Maybe a fact I'll give
you twenty seconds. That gives you ten seconds
to get onto the URL. So get onto
the buzzer page very quick.
First one to buzz in gets to come
and join me and take a shot at
this cluster.
I am gonna post the link one more
time into this
chat.
Alright. Buzzer's unlocking.
I'm not gonna tell you when.
I'm just gonna do it.
Alright. Bogdan, you are up. Please come on,
join the link that is in the YouTube
chat.
And then we'll decide what customer you wanna
take a pop at.
And
I do trust you, Benjamin, but I'm just
gonna remove you from the
team.
Person.
There we go.
Hello. Welcome.
Hey.
Alright. I've got lots of people trying to
dial in now, so please only come in
when you're invited. Maybe I should have come
up with a better delivery system for that
URL.
Hey. How are you, man?
I'm good. I'm good. Alright. Awesome. I wanted
to to go first, but I was a
bit afraid.
So
yeah. Well, one of the things that we
try to do with cluster is to, like,
try to dismantle this hero culture that we
have. Like, we all know some stuff. We
all know we all don't know a lot
more. So it's alright when we Google. It's
okay if we say we don't know, and
we try to work on the answer together.
Vladimir, please stop trying to die. Alright.
So could you please type your GitHub username
into the interview chat on this web page?
I will add you to the team.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's a a chat.
Yeah. Okay. I
will get you added to the team, and
then you have the choice between continuing with
cluster one or trying cluster two.
How do I write in the chat?
I mean, you can just tell me your
GitHub username if you if you want. It's
l Bogdan.
L. So Bogdan with an l.
Gotcha.
Alright. You now have an email with an
invitation to the team. Please accept that, and
then we'll get you access to this cluster.
Yes.
Got it.
Join.
Okay.
Let's
okay. I joined.
Alright. If you go to join.clustered.live
in your web browser.
Yes.
And I guess I have to log in.
Yep. Authenticate with GitHub.
And then if you click on activity
and active sessions
Oh, wait. What cluster do want to work
on? Do you want to continue with cluster
one, or do wanna go on to Let's
continue.
Alright. Then you'll see an active session
under activity menu on the left, and then
please click options and join.
Okay. For login name,
I can use Root. Oh, Root. Oh, no.
Yeah. But you have to join, not open
a new session.
Oh, okay. Click activity on the left, and
then there's active sessions.
I I I can show you.
So activity active sessions and then options and
join. Activity
active sessions.
Yep.
Yeah. I want
to look into Teleport
one of these days. Alright. Looks like you're
in the session. So if you can just
type echo hello, let me know that you're
there. Thank you.
Teleport is awesome. It's such a cool tool.
Alright. So you're continuing from where Benjamin left
us.
So what's your thought process so far? And
your ten minutes section there. Well, I I
guess
it's this is not running.
I see some container
d, so I guess we're using container d.
That's correct.
So
okay.
Then I guess we should look at
few.
I think you mean. Right?
Yeah.
I'm a bit nervous.
I I feel like
on a on a job interview.
Every day someone's on clustered, typing is your
the first thing that goes. Yeah. I mean,
while watching, it seems easy.
But then when you're on the spot, it's
like, oh, what should I do now?
Okay. So
controller manager
failed to get status.
I guess these are
k. So let's do it like this
and look for that CD.
No. It's d.
K.
Manifests
tier.
Sorry. I'm I'm laughing at my own maliciousness
now.
It's just I don't know if you know
what's the timestamps on those files, but it
made me laugh.
The what? The timestamps on the files.
Oh, okay.
It's in the future.
Yeah.
What do we have here?
This seems
not okay.
But
I I think the time stamps are super
freshly. You can ignore that. I just I'm
laughing. That's all. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It
was a red herring. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For
sure.
But it's weird that we don't get any
Yeah. I would have expected there to be
etcd logs and the kubelet to be trying
to start it.
So yeah.
Weird.
Kind of weird.
Is
the
cubelet binary
untempered yet? It's untempered. If I have not
recompelled the cubelet, that I can tell you.
Okay.
Why would it
okay. Let's see.
But, yeah, I I guess the
manifest folder
is set correctly
because it seems like it's
trying to start the other
static pods
or not.
Yep. So you're talking about a kubelet flag
that allows you to specify a different directory
for the static manifest.
You can confirm that if you want. I'm
happy to tell you that it's not changed.
But it should be looking in the Etsy
Kubernetes manifest.
Yes, Russell. You are the only person who
has recompiled the Kubelet. You evil evil person.
Advertiser.
Okay. So why would the kubelet
not start
a static pod
defined in the manifest folder?
Do we have this?
I find a
good way to kind of check this. Restarting
the Kubelet and you've tailing the logs from
the start usually does reveal a bit more
information.
You got five minutes left. Yeah. Okay.
Let's actually
would can we
do we have screen? You
can use screen. Yep. Okay.
That's
Loading cert starting controller.
Okay.
Let's see.
K. So I
see for creating
already exist.
And then get
preparing.
So did you see anything for ETD there?
I yeah. I saw this, the deleted smear
pod.
And then I saw
failed to
something about probe.
But
okay. Let's leave it like this.
So
it looks like we have
Good cold dropping down to cray control. I
think that that should help.
Yeah. I'm not sure how.
Copy paste.
I can do that for you if you
want. Oh, you got it.
Okay. A bit more
oh, no.
Find oh, because it's
p s.
Let's see. Looks
like it's running.
Copy.
Is there a way to
easy copy
and paste?
You just have to what operating system are
you on?
Windows Chrome?
Yeah. Control c and control v in your
browser should hopefully work just just fine. Yeah.
I tried, but it didn't seem to work.
Okay.
So
cache is open.
Does it work now?
Oh, okay.
So
it somehow
fixed it.
I have no idea why.
It it shouldn't help?
No.
Okay.
But, you know, the the name of the
game is the update image. So if it
works, it works. But, yeah, I'm I'm a
bit confused by that.
So now
we're two.
So you have to upgrade the clustered application
from v one to v two.
Do we have canines?
No. We do not. Do
we have nano?
Yeah.
The name cluster.
Oh,
no.
How do I
well, I guess I don't.
Where is the image? So to v two.
Is it working?
Can you still still see my screen?
Yeah. Run kubectl
get pods.
Do we have a new pod?
We do not. Okay. Did not.
Interesting.
Do we have a Oh, look at that.
The controller manager is also broken.
Yeah. Alright. You've got about one minute left.
Okay.
Yeah. Just let me know when
You've made amazing progress. I I have no
idea why that API
server is working right now.
What
can you
say what
should have been the the issue? I'll wait
till the end of the episode just
in case it comes back and breaks again.
I don't wanna give it away, but we'll
we'll go over the break and for sure.
HTTP
probe failed.
So I guess there's a liveness probe
and
manifest
cube.
Controller manager, I think.
Can I remove it?
Yeah. Or You can if you want.
I'll let you finish finish this change, and
we'll see if anything's working. And then we'll
swap you out for someone else because you're
a little bit over, but I'll let you
finish what you're working on. Oh, okay. Okay.
Yeah.
That's fine. That's the manager
usually
has
have a RIPE NOS pro? It does indeed.
Yes.
Describe.
Yes. We should
oh,
yeah.
You can move it out and back in.
That's a good trick. Yep. It usually helps
speed it up. Alright. The comments are saying
that Benjamin did actually run a cube admin
in a on a machine.
I didn't clock that. It must have skipped
past me when I was
looking at the comments.
Cool. But I think that should be okay.
I don't think we keep
in it.
Whatever. Think I changed. But
I'll check. I'll check.
And we
dot
Okay. It's restarting. Yep.
You have a controller manager.
And
my cluster
pod
is still
not doing anything.
Just
on this, and then I'll pass it over.
A wrong name, Swiss.
Oh, yeah.
The part may have been rotated.
Okay.
Is it using the new meter?
Let's check.
There are local host on port 30,000.
It it seems like it does, but yeah.
Local host. 38,000.
That's 30,000.
You got v two. Well done.
Yay.
Alright. Thanks for
Yes. Me see. An email, and I will
hook you up with your $200 Amazon voucher.
I have no idea why it's fixed, but
does it matter? You fixed it, so well
done.
It it happens sometime. Like, you you fix
it and you don't know why it works.
Well, let's take a look at some of
the breaks in this machine. Right? So if
we take a look at the Kubernetes
manifest
now the Kubernetes may have broken may have
fixed this,
but I'm not sure. Oh, I need to
test the browser because the
then causes a little bit of trouble.
I changed the name of
the entity
node in the manifest. So, actually,
the entity shouldn't have been able to come
back up,
which I'm a little bit confused, but it
did
because its real name is one.
Yeah. One. Yeah.
But
oh, let's see. I would have probably not
called that.
Also, nobody said an alias,
which is It's bit quite
weird with, like, changing
underlying IPs or host names or, like, it
kind
of breaks and you need to manually
fix it.
So yeah. But it came back on that,
and that that's the only mission. The the
other gotcha here was that if you'd set
an alias decay, which 99%
of people do,
things would have been a little bit broken.
But because you kept using kubectl
in fact, no. Now it's broken. S e
z is now broken. Anyway.
Oh, well. Yeah. I changed the auto complete
on the k alias to be the get
command. So
just as a mails annoyance to people. But
it doesn't matter. Like I said, please drop
an email david@rockwood.com.
I will hook you up with that feature,
and thank you for for joining. We've got
one more cluster to fix that I'm gonna
get someone else on.
Yeah. Thank you for having me. Cheers.
Alright.
Damn you, cluster.
Cool. Alright. I'm gonna open the buzzers again.
So if you wanna come on and take
a pop at cluster number two,
we've got more Amazon vouchers to give away.
The link is there. I'll give you all
another ten, fifteen seconds to get back into
the buzzer room if you're not already, and
then I'm going to unlock the buzzers.
No
idea how it's a d got back online
there.
That's annoying.
Alright. I'm going to unlock the buzzers at
a random moment.
Said you were close, but FHKE
was
first.
So
link has gone into the YouTube chat.
Please come and join me, FHKE.
I will get you access to cluster two.
I'll open a session just now.
I'm looking forward to this one,
I think.
Alright. I'll give you another
twenty seconds, FHKE
and then oh, there we go.
Nice.
Hello.
Hey. How's it going?
Yeah. Well, I'm a bit disappointed that my
first break was only partial break, but sometimes
that happens on clusters. I'm not gonna dwell
on it. How are how are you doing?
Yeah. Yeah. Good. Thanks.
Alright. Can
you
give me your GitHub username, please?
Yeah. Sure. It's f h k. So that's
the one I use for here.
K. Let's get you added.
So you're gonna get an email just now.
If you just click on that and accept
the invitation and then go to join.cluster.live.
We will get you into cluster number two.
So we haven't seen anything to do with
cluster number two, so you're starting from a
fresh slate.
Good stuff.
Dan asks, is this the first live Kubernetes
debugging session you've hosted?
No. No. We have over 42 episodes of
clustered. This is the first one we've made
interactive with the audience actually participating,
but there are loads and loads of episodes
of clustered on the channel. So go to
rockwood.live and check that out.
Russell asking, can I save the session history?
Yeah. The session history will be there in
the other log of Teleport and in the
bash history. I'm I'm gonna go back through
it and see if I can work with
what happened. It did appear SGD was broken
at the end there as well.
So
but the the image was updated, so I
can't I can't argue.
So Where do I need to go to?
If you go to your email, you should
have a GitHub team invitation.
Yeah. I've just joined that GitHub. Oh, alright.
Okay. So if you go to join .clustered.live,
Andrew is asking which episode was the Unicode
one. Search for clustered Guy Templeton
or Guinevere,
who was my host cohost on that episode.
And that is the one with the Unicode
break that we never speak of again.
Alright. So if you're logged on to, Teleport
now, if you expand the activity menu
you go to active sessions. Cool.
Yeah. I can see that. And then options
and join,
and then just type echo hello, anything to
let me know that you're in this session.
Awesome.
I will export your KubeConfig for you, and
then the cluster is all yours for the
next ten minutes.
And I'll fix my spelling as well.
Alright.
All yours. Cool. Best of luck.
I'm sorry. What's the challenge on this one?
Same again. Upgrade the clustered application from v
one to v two.
Okay. No event.
The pending salema operator is okay and can
be ignored.
Okay.
The chat comments are assisting you here if
you can see them.
Yeah. No. Sorry. I missed the I really
thought I've done that.
It's just a clustered with a k,
Like, Rawkode with a key.
Oh,
where'd it go?
I think staying it down.
What's going be done?
Good question.
Can't see anything obviously there.
No. No. No.
Guess, though.
I wonder if there are any comm jobs
or anything.
Yep. Current jobs.
I can look in the APIs overall, but
it logs up there. What's up?
They don't have. What
were you looking for in the manifest there?
Just see if the audit log was set
up for the API seven.
I
should set them up, actually. That would that
would be good.
An improvement for future clusters, I think.
I can just sleep there. So what's that?
What's the current amount?
So I'm gonna guess this is some kind
of loop, and every six sixty seconds, it's
gonna scale it down.
This is the cluster that I broke Carl
off. Yeah.
Yes. My job is to laugh, Carlos, not
to help.
This is the only episode of Clustered where
I have not been on
the line with someone else for fixing. So
I'm enjoying this one.
I mean, I'm wishing I had had those
sleep processes in the process table with LD
preload, but
that may have been a bit too mean.
But there's definitely stuff in roll capping on
this machine.
You got five minutes left.
So you ran who, checking for other users.
You'd run jobs to see if there was
anything scheduled.
Nothing so far. If you could choose a
pager on the longer commands, it just means
we see what you see as well for
you.
Yeah. Sure. Thank you.
It's obviously running.
See, this is one of the breaks where
I was like, this is super sneaky. And
then five minutes before we went live, I
was like, it's too obvious. Like, it's just
far too obvious. And now I'm not I'm
I'm so swayed. I don't know.
I hope you find it because I want
I've I've gotta talk about it, but let's
let's see what happens.
Yeah.
Clone would be too easy, wouldn't it?
Peter has just joined and is asking what
is the issue. Well, the issue is
that
every time our
deployment is scaled from zero replicas to a
positive number,
Some rogue process appears
to be scaling it back to zero.
We are looking for that process.
I mean, if it's running on the host,
maybe I could just move the KubeConfig somewhere
else, and it would fail to authenticate.
I like that.
Very clever.
Terminal
just.
If you need to resize the window, it
does help. It's a bug in xterm JS.
Just resizing it by, like, one pixel does
seem to kick it back in line or
type in reset as a command.
Oh, yeah. Seems to be working now.
Okay. It's happening again. So it's not probably
not something running on the hose.
So maybe it's, I guess, on a container.
Potentially.
Yeah.
Alright. You have two minute.
I like your process here, though. You're doing
well.
Thanks.
Yeah. I can't see anything, but, like, obviously,
they'll be doing this when I get good
data.
Depends whether you trust all the names of
the processes, I guess.
That's true.
There's a really cool command for debugging every
image in the cluster. I am not saying
that's gonna give you any information whatsoever,
but
you never know.
You're already doing it.
So where did they make that one?
Which one?
This one here.
I can't see what you select. You'll need
to Sorry. It's the one that begins SHA256.
Yeah. That's just that's just one that's resolved
to a sha. If you were to on
your Gret, do a cap dash capital b
two, it would also show you the name,
I think, before it. So it could be
extra matchers.
So before the dash I do. Yeah.
All right, you got about thirty seconds and
then I'll swap you out.
But I feel that you've made really good
progress for people here.
Alright. Your time Yep.
Nice work, though. Very well done. Yeah. Thank
you.
Yeah. Drop me an email, david@rawkode.com.
I'm gonna send that to my other time.
And I'll put it into the the comments
as well at the end of the episode.
But, yeah, you got a an Amazon voucher.
Thank you for joining me. And Thank you.
Let's see who else wants to come on.
Alright. The link for the buzzer is there.
I'll give these all twenty seconds to get
ready. I'll unlock them at a random moment
in time. First one to buzz does get
to come on and join and see if
they can fix this cluster.
Vladimir,
you are first. Please
join the stream.
The link is in the chat. I'll see
you in a minute.
Carlos, a a different cluster or the same
one? It is the same cluster. I only
broke two clusters for today's episode. The first
one was fixed by
magic.
Hey, Vladimir. How's it going?
Can you hear me okay?
Yeah. One second. I will turn off the
stream.
Okay. I'm with you.
So I need to send you my GitHub
account. One second. Please do. Yeah.
Asked me if you can have an Equinix
metal voucher. Use Rawkode. That will get you
$200 in credits for Equinix metal.
Can I just tell you the my login?
Because You can. For some reason, I shut
up on chat. Okay. O I k seven
four one. Alright.
O
I k seven four one. Right?
Yep. Nice shift. Right.
Alright. You have an email inviting you to
the team.
Please check it out. Accept the invite, and
then go to join.cluster.live.
We already have a session active,
so you'll be able to continue
from where Farragall left us.
I will share my screen so you can
see what you're looking for as well.
You want to come to active sessions under
the activity menu on the left.
Once you've accepted the invite, join dot clustered
dot by. Yep.
Activity.
Active sessions.
Transition.
Sessions. I'm in. Alright. Type echo hello. Anything
you want. Does that there we go. I
can see you type it already. You're
carrying on from where Fergo left us, so,
you know, best of luck. You've got ten
minutes.
Sorry. I have a buddy here. That's alright.
I've got two cats of my own. I
know. I'll do well. So
Yeah.
Something is scaling a replica or deployment a
replica set time to zero. I
saw here.
It's half Postgres. Oh, because she said I
can't get. It's just k logs.
I'm
like,
Oh, okay. Sorry. Sorry. Yep. Yeah. So I'll
remove the get. There you go.
Alice,
Okay.
Yeah.
It looks like real.
Then
for some reason, mom's face me.
Me.
You're checking all the images right now.
Oh, so it's was just just a pseudo
images.
Yeah.
Mean, previous guy was suspecting
something that caused this.
He's over to this chase, and it was
just silly. Sorry,
guys. I can't proceed. I need to Of
course. No problem. To my daughter. Sorry. Sorry,
guys. No. That's all good. Yeah. Thank you
for coming on. See you. Bye.
Alright.
I know that feeling all too well. I
have a three and a half year old
daughter
and an eight month old son.
So we'll get Vladimir on for another episode.
That's for sure.
Alright. Let's get the buzzers back up. So
the link is at the top of the
page.
I'm gonna unlock them in a few moments.
First one to buzz in can come and
join us.
Alistair, first one in.
When you come.
Hey, friends with this.
Hello.
Alright.
I should know this, but please tell me
your GitHub username.
Well, how do I type? You can just
oh, you can type that into the interview
chat on the web page that you joined
from, or you can tell it to me.
Can you see that?
Yep. I can. It's in the guest chat.
Wonderful.
Alright. You have an email with an invitation
to this team.
Please accept it.
I will. And while I'm doing that, you
can sell
kubeadle to everyone.
You're right. I can't believe I haven't mentioned
that yet. So I am organizing a Kubernetes
conference in Scotland.
You can go to kubeadle.com
where you can get information on our twenty
twenty two conference.
We are in Edinburgh, Scotland's capital, in October.
So go check out the website, and, hopefully,
I'll see some of you in October.
Alright. So if you could It's
my wife's birthday on the third.
So she's getting a trip to Edinburgh. Right?
Well, she she was going to, but then
oh, cluster.live.
Yep. Join .clusters.live.
I authenticate with your GitHub username. There we
go. And then please go to activity active
sessions and join the session that we have
open right now.
Yeah. She was gonna come, but then it's
it's DevOps days London on the Thursday, Friday.
So that makes it a bit
Ah.
Interesting.
Once you're in the session, if you could
please type echo hello or anything like that
to let me know that you're there. Perfect.
You have ten minutes. Best of luck.
So
It's very different when you're on this side
of the screen, I've got to say.
Your ability to take will follow the window,
I guarantee it.
I was just checking in case you put
the deployment YAML in here, and it was
being auto
sort of sculped down or something like that.
Where do we start? There's that command to
get all the images. I'm just gonna Google
it because I can never remember.
I
tend to use git control cluster dash and
full dump and then grab for image. Yeah.
I wonder if I can paste.
No.
Paste.
Okay.
What's the namespace? It's.
Alright.
Oh, it's before.
It's really annoying.
These two things. This sounds like some nice
twitches on that keyboard. What are you rocking?
M x Browns, I think.
Oh, nice. I only have one mechanical keyboard,
which
shocks some people. I currently just got the
Keychron q three, which I am loving right
now. Although it is a heavy beast. So
Very nice. Is that, like, metal aluminum
thingy? Yeah. I got the knob version, so,
like, I can use that for random stuff.
Don't let me distract you from fixing the
cluster at all.
What's Kubefit DS and Kubefit? Kubefit is what
we use to advertise the BGP address on
this echo Xpero cluster. You can ignore Kubefit
for today.
Okay.
CTR.
What was that other one that that does
the CRI one? CRI CTR, is it? That's
the one. Yeah.
Yes.
Agent. What's agent?
Oh, emissary
ingress agent.
KubeScheduler.
I'm just doing the same things that everyone
else does.
Okay. So in case I see something different,
well, that unless you can see it.
Root root root.
Look for the hybrid things.
There's people saying stuff in chat that might
help me. Not yet. No.
Oh. I think we've stopped a lot of
hopefully, I've stopped a lot of people with
this one. Although Carlos is suggesting that you
check your mutation webhook.
Andrew thinks maybe something in an in a
container.
What is it? Mutating
Mutating webhook configuration.
Look.
Configurations.
Bug down 40 sleep, 60 in the process
table. Yep.
How can I not spell mutating?
Mutating
webhook config. Yeah. That's right. Right?
It's actually being made. Run kubectl
API dash resources and get from music.
Which
one has sleep? Sleep.
There's a way to see the process tree.
If I pick a ped
Yes. You can see the process tree.
And I can never remember how to do
it.
E f e f a u x would
be a good way to do it.
PS. What is it? E f? A u
AUX.
Well,
if you come up for sleep, you won't
see the process tree.
And if you use a pager, it means
we see what you see.
Thank you.
And
then we can search for sleep.
I mean, there's lots of harmless reasons sleep
could be running. Is there all
down and on sleep here? We all use
sleep in our scripts. Right?
What are you thinking?
See. I don't know.
What am I doing wrong?
CRI.
CRI CTL.
What subscribed purely to comment on the mutating
typo? Thank you, bot.
Oh, what did I do?
Mutating.
I don't know. It's been too long since
we Too many a t a t a
t a t I n g's, I think.
Andrew is asking what's the KubePap pod that
is not named for the not named.
CubePad also runs a small
daemon set to advertise the BGP on every
machine. And the control plane one is the
leader election
and services routine stuff.
State not ready. It's because it's being
is it being paused
Or something.
What's doing that? What could do that?
Good comments there from Carlos and Bogdan.
Not that I want you to be able
to fix this or anything, but those are
good comments.
Carlos says concentrate in the process table.
If we need to, we'll jump into EBPF.
How's your EBPF, Allison?
Terrible.
Fuck Dan noticed ATQ
maybe.
I don't know what ATQ is.
What is ATQ?
It is a
command runner on Linux.
Settler for cron.
How do I view them? Minus
minus b. No. Q.
Oh, we can never send mail to the
user.
Minus c.
Nope.
Cool.
Someone was saying
processes. Yeah.
Everything's in everything's everything's running as a process.
Everything is a process.
Everything's a process. I mean, the PSEUXEF,
I mean, it shows you much more than
I think you
you you actually paid attention to.
Again, not that I want you to fix
this, but
there's a lot of information on this Yeah.
System d.
No.
Something's
running Chrome.
SSHD is running.
You've got one minute.
Playing flies when you're having fun. Right? I
know. Yeah.
Contained the share.
There's so many things on here.
Teleport.
Bash. Woo hoo.
Bugged
down. Somebody already moved admin.com
away,
and that made no difference.
Mhmm.
Just delete all the pods.
Please don't delete all the pods.
That's usually what I do
on the managed cluster when stuff's not working.
Alright. Your time is up, Alistair.
Thank you for joining us. Please email me,
david@rockwood.com.
I will get you the Amazon voucher,
and we will invite someone else on. Thanks,
man.
Alright.
So the link is on the page. CosmoBuzz.net
blah blah blah blah blah.
Get your buzzers ready. I will be unlocking
the buzzers a moment's early. First one to
buzz, the guest to come on and join
me. I think we'll do two more people.
We'll try and finish this at seven.
And then if it's not fixed, I will
run through the break on this cluster.
That oh.
Well, it said Dan, but now said it
was first. So I think it that's some
sort of weird sync on the buzzer. So
said, click the link and come and join
me.
I will paste it one more time.
And I will wait here patiently for Seth
to join us.
Seth has been active in the chat so
far, so I know he's got ideas.
Curious to see if he's gonna get to
the bottom of this skill down.
And I think Dan's the only other person
in the buzzer that's not been on. So
Dan, we'll get you on after Seth if
Seth doesn't fix it.
Because that was pretty close. So Dan, you
are next.
Hey, Sid.
Hey.
How's it going?
I'm having fun. Are you having fun?
I am. I am.
Alright. Dan's joining us too. Dan, you can
fix it next. Right? We're gonna give Seth
ten minutes and then and then Dan. So
thank you both for joining me. Alright. Seth,
let's get you access to this cluster.
Cool. My GitHub is just first name, last
name, Sid Palace.
Yep.
Alright. You have an email.
Please go check it. Accept the invite and
go to join.cluster.live.
You know the drill. You have been here
before.
Join
join Rawkode Academy. Well done asking if execs
note is installed on the server. No. But
you're more than welcome to install BCC tools
if you want to execs note.
And then what's the the URL to join
the teleport? Join.clustered.live.
Alright.
Once you're logged in, please go to activity
followed by active sessions
and join the session that we have opened
just now on
two control plan one.
And then just type echo hello or anything
like that so that we know you're in
the same session.
Perfect.
Alright. You got ten minutes starting now. Best
of luck.
Okay.
Great.
So, yeah, I think there were a couple
of things that Alistair was doing that seemed
useful.
Someone had suggested a t q, and so
I think a t dash l will give
us
anything
scheduled there. It looks like nothing.
Another potential place we could schedule stuff
would be with
system CTL
timers, I guess.
Let's see.
So if we do
is it just timers or list timers?
List timers, I believe. Right? List
dash timers. One more well Yeah. No space.
Interest and hypothesis, Dan.
When I tell you what the break is
or you discover the break, I'll talk about
something that's important.
Maybe.
Alright. So what are thinking?
Nothing
there
jumps out at me.
We
people had suggested looking at containers running on
the host.
Cry control always confuses me, so maybe I'll
try to install NerdControl because it is
more familiar.
Yep. Do we go do See what happens.
Dot local ben is not in the path,
so you will have to modify it or
push it to somewhere else.
It seems to be you pushed it to
home slash dot local then.
That
should be it.
Okay.
Nothing there.
Kubernetes pods run-in a namespace
that you would have to
And so to add a namespace in nerd
c t l, I'm just gonna Google that.
Try dash capital e. It might do all
namespaces.
Good idea. I think after the p s.
Nope.
Or for shop. Then you may have to
do dash n create style.
Apparently, I don't know how to work Nerd
Control or Nerd Control.
Oh, there you go. Here we go. It
needs to be before PS.
K.
Everything came up seven hours ago.
We do have this
pause container.
So you think the malicious workload is in
a container?
I wasn't sure about that, but I I
figured we should look at them as a
starting point.
But,
yeah, nothing here looks particularly
interesting
unless I'm
skimming over it in the with the the
pressure of the stream on me. You know?
You know, it's amazing how quickly we should
get everything we've ever known the minute cameras
in front of your face. Right?
So you're just scrolling up and down this
list right now?
Yeah. It was just looking at well, I
I made my screen large enough that I
didn't have to scroll. But
Just looking at the commands that they're all
issuing.
Venom is curious if the pod is scaling
itself down.
Leszek Yes. It's fine. Is it going to
be something like a bash script pushed into
the background of a session?
Peter is asking if the images are real.
Alastair's looking for processes running Python or parallel.
Lots of ideas.
Wonderful ideas, but they're all wrong.
Get
deploy clustered. Kind of. Maybe.
Yeah. So there's no in it container or
anything on there.
Would have been a good way to do
it. The same effect, I guess. But, yeah,
not how it's done today. That would have
been
would have been neat.
Let's look at the postgres one.
Yeah.
Wesley's asking, consistently triggers fire when a pod
starts.
Interesting.
I'm not entirely sure, to be honest. No
idea.
Yeah. So Postgres appears to
Russell's asking if the process runs on another
node. These are single node clusters
for the record and
no external hardware we choose.
I'm afraid you've only got one minute left.
It
Yeah. It it flew by.
I have been rather sneaky with this one,
I have to say. I was unconfident
coming into this. Like, I know people are
gonna get it too quickly, but I I'm
glad that this has stumped people because
there's something important to learn at the end
of this episode.
What was the the flag on PS to
see the tree?
E f a u x. E f will
give you the tree and a u x
will show you all the processes.
I think the f stands for forest.
That's what they call the tree in the
PS format.
Nice. That's it. HPAs were checked. Yep.
Well, Dan, glad he didn't choose this one.
Dan, still very a lot of people curious
about the ATD.
I'll give you another Yeah. Think thirty seconds
that what do got? No. I I think
I'm ready to hand it over. I don't
have any ideas that'll bear that'll bear fruit
in thirty seconds.
Alright. Well, thank you for coming on. It's
always a pleasure. Please email me david@rawkode.com.
I'll hook you up with that voucher, and
then we'll hand it over to Dan. Now,
Dan, please come and join us. Thanks, Ed.
Yeah. Thanks.
Alright. I'm just gonna leave this up here.
Dan,
please click that link again. We'll get you
added to the cluster.
I'll okay. I'll share one again.
There you go.
Alex, joined late. What's the symptom?
Our deployment and replica set has been scaled
to zero,
and no one has been able to work
out how or why
yet.
Hey, Dan. Hey.
Thanks for joining us.
Can you Okay. What do I need to
do next? Give me your GitHub username, please.
I think it's Dan Kirkpatrick. Let me I'm
not sure, to be honest.
Let me check my one password.
GitHub.
Yeah. It's dan.kirkpatrick@gmail.com.
Alright. This may be you. Please check your
email and see if you have an invite
to
add a team on the Rawkode Academy. If
you do, please accept it. There
it is. Alright. Join Rawkode Academy.
Join.
I'm in, but
Now you can go.
I'll paste you the link into the chat,
but it is join.clustered.live.
This will ask you to authenticate against GitHub,
and then you will have access to the
session that we are in just now.
Alright. I've lost my window now.
There we are.
Share.
I don't see the text window on the
on the chat.
Oh, there it is. I see it. It's
on the side. It's on the side. Yeah.
Anybody check the
So if you go to that link, join
.cluster.live,
you'll be able to join my session.
Join dot I don't see a link.
Just go to your browser, join .clustered.live.
Join .clustered.live.
Let's try that out.
Can't find that server cluster with a k?
K. Oops. I missed all the clustered. My
bad. Yep.
That didn't work either.
Clustered.live.
So join .clustered.live.
I'll type it again and speak a chitchat
as that.
Dot live.
I'm
no. That doesn't work either.
And I've lost my YouTube window now. I'm
gonna have to to bow out because I
I'm having technical issues.
Alright. No worries. Well, send me an email.
We'll get you an Amazon voucher. Thank you
for jumping on. Okay.
I'm not sure I deserve that, but thanks.
Well,
alright. Do we have any last calls? Does
anybody want to join us before we we
give away the secret sauce here?
You wanna join?
Let me know.
Dustin asking, has anyone described the replica set
events? We have seen the events on the
replica set. We're scaling up and something is
scaling it down.
Russell is asking about OS cron versus Kubernetes
cron. Could it be cron?
Well, as it says Cron jobs were empty.
Any takers?
Alright, I am just gonna post a link.
Anyone that wants to come on and have
a go at this, please click the link.
We will not be rebuilding the cluster from
scratch.
Alright. I'm gonna give it one more minute
and then I will walk through the break.
If anybody wants a chance at fixing this
before I reveal it, now is your opportunity.
Bogdan, maybe you wanna come back on and
try it?
Dan, feel free to jump back on. Dan,
if you've got the link when you come.
Yeah.
Alright.
Hello.
Alright. Hello.
Hey.
Okay.
Let me see. I
still have this open.
What was your username again?
There we go. Sorry?
It's a different team for this cluster, so
I will add you to that. So it
will automatically add you this time, so you
may have to
just reload
your teleport page.
In fact, I can always change the roles.
Oh, that's better. One. Because she gave you
one earlier.
I will just give you access to everything
so you don't have to reload.
Please join the active session and type echo
hello or something so that I know you're
here.
Okay.
Is that your production
account?
Which one?
No. No. I was just joking. I I
asked if that's your production account.
Yeah. These are my production clusters we're fixing.
I actually don't know what's wrong with them.
Okay.
So
should I see it in the active sessions?
Yep. You should hopefully be able to see
the active sessions. Looks like Dan is on
a note.
Join the first one. One. Right?
To control plane one. The first session, forty
nine minutes old.
Join that one. Join.
I mean, I I said yes, but I
have literally no idea.
Can
I get hints
to to
maybe
get it over with faster? Like, is it
something on the host, or is it something
in the cluster?
It is something on the host, and Dan
has been very close a few times by
telling us to look at the at daemon.
Oh, okay. So a t d a t
q. I mean, that is definitely how
the rogue processes are being scheduled.
Okay. So can I just do
I mean, you can stop it, but I'd
like you to faint the the bad thing
too?
Okay.
Do we have the scale here? Okay.
That's annoying.
Like, I
oh, okay.
Where did this come from?
Didn't you we already run ATQ? And
Yeah. Something you did triggered some schedules.
Oh, okay.
But how
do they still run if ATD is stopped?
We've had someone else join, but I don't
think
Joe, are you there?
Like, if there's
Right. Someone who wants to try, I can
just
Dan removed all the ATQ commands, and they
came back. That's that's a pain in the
ass.
I don't think anyone's got any ideas.
Oh, okay. Interesting.
Is this some tampered with?
CubeControl is not tampered with. No. Interesting
idea.
Alright. I'm gonna just start dropping hints so
that we can uncover what's actually happening here.
But I find it interesting
that people are running kubectl
in a very trustful fashion.
So
how does kubectl know how to speak to
our API server?
Oh, okay.
Well,
did you set it?
Oh, okay.
Is there, like
yeah.
So tricky.
I guess
oh, because it's
we also have
oh.
So the comments seem to think that I
set up an alias or a function for
cube control. I have not. This is 100%
a perfectly legal break.
So there was something in that
admin.com
that should be investigated.
The cube boss metal?
Mhmm.
So do you know what that is?
Just a take on which?
I mean, it is a command that KubeCTL
runs and then it gets a token, right,
or something like it's
Yeah. So if we take a look at
Like, an external
Like authentication.
Exactly. Right? So the this is called Kubernetes
or a kube control authentication helper.
Mostly for managed Kubernetes clusters like AWS and
GCP where you don't have a specific token
and you run a command and it gets
a token.
But there's nothing stopping that command from doing
malicious things in your cluster.
Yeah. So, actually,
our way sorry, sir.
Our way Yeah. I'll let you drive it.
And if we run a tape on this,
we'll see that we have a
binary, which I thought was particularly mean of
me.
A fail. Fail? Yeah. That's what I meant.
As I I mean, we don't really have
any visibility into
what this is doing
at all.
We could run strings on it.
Yeah. And I guess you And you may
you may see something interesting or you may
not. Yeah.
Actually, you don't really see that much.
But what I wanted people to be aware
of with this is that, like, those authentication
helpers are really opaque, you should never really
trust a KubeConfig without knowing what it's actually
doing.
I have stored a plain bash version of
the script on the host, which I can
show you if you wish.
Yeah.
Which I sneakily did it. How how
would you
go and fix it?
Because
So that's what our authentication helper is actually
doing.
Okay. It sets up a so because this
happens before the kube control command,
I had to use at to sleep them
for five, thirty, and sixty seconds.
So they would run afterwards.
That's what I your
cube control
modifications would actually work for a short period
of time, and then it would all go
to shit.
And then I could parallel it with SHC,
which gives you a binary of any shell
script that kinda make us a bit more
hidden. But that was it.
The fix here is
not to use that gip config and to
instead use trusted credentials,
which I have left.
You can see
here,
we have used our local BEN
cache,
which is a real
credential file.
Oh, okay.
Yeah. And that's all the the results for
dot key and dot certificate.
Yeah. But it's it's it's really, really easy
to write a bad KubeConfig authentication helper that
does lots of nasty stuff inside of a
cluster. Like, I mean, all I'm doing here
is cat and out some
very important credentials.
Yeah. But I I think
exec snoop would have helped because
you would be able to see
that kubectl
executed
that those helper.
And then yeah. Yeah. Let's let's do it.
Let's because I like BCC tools. I just
don't remember the name of the package, but
search.
Maybe
in one word.
Oh, no. BPS CC tools. Yeah.
Carlos is asking how I would debug this.
I would use execs note to debug this
%.
So let me open a second session.
We could run exec snip.
We could run our acute control.
We've got a scale command here somewhere, don't
we? Yep.
And
probably should have felt this on a few
things, but Yeah. That's alright.
Let's see. Yeah. There we go. I've got
our three act commands being run. You can
see our cube control scale, which is then
Mhmm. We've got our off metal
and then off metal as you run-in the
the acts. We could see the certificates
that are being kind of injected in.
So everything you kind of need, that is
available for exact.
The BPF tools are awesome. Right? I I
I really feel that everybody should learn all
of these. There's loads of them. Yeah. Actually,
if we do
a s
user local PIN
rep,
where do they live?
No. I think it's in
Oh, Spend.
There there's a lot of scripts in
user share
BCC
or something.
Yeah. I guess
We got exact snip, kill snip, mount snip.
Open snip is one of my favorites. That's
fucking awesome.
In fact, we'd see
I'll grab it because I know what I'm
looking for.
If we grab for cash,
it's not too noisy.
Oh, that was too noisy.
We would have seen the credential files in
there as as well. So, yeah, all those
not kills are pretty cool.
Yeah.
Alright. Thank you, Bogdan.
Thank you a lot again. Cheers. Bye.
Alright. Thank you everybody for watching the community
versus Rawkode episode of Clustert. Clustert is on
every single week on my channel except for
when I'm traveling. I'm actually at CD con
in Austin, Texas next week, so there won't
be Clustered.
But we will be back the following week.
So, hopefully, I will see you all then.
Remember to subscribe to the channel, like the
video, and, hopefully, I see you all again
soon.
So thank you for tuning in. And I
think, actually, this was a whole lot more
fun than I expected. So I'm gonna run
more community versus Rawkode episodes
and see if we can do this again.
So I'll get that maybe once a month.
Let's see. Alright. Thank you, everybody. Have a
wonderful evening.